das ist la coruna aus osaka der 21
jährige arbeitet in einem supermarkt und
singt in einer rockband und das ist
seine freundin man ak 16 jahre alt sie
sind ein paar in der beziehung
simulation love plus sakko schlüpft ihr
in die rolle eines schülers die
virtuelle man ak hat er im spiel kennen
gelernt
im spiel war ich damals gerade neu auf
der schule und habe beschlossen beim
tennis team vorbeizuschauen dort habe
ich mag a das erste mal gesehen sie war
gerade bei der gartenarbeit und wir
haben angefangen uns zu unterhalten so
hat unsere beziehung begonnen seitdem
sind wir uns immer näher gekommen
nur verbringt täglich etwa drei stunden
mit seiner virtuellen freundin sie ist
immer dabei denn love plus läuft auf dem
mobilen nintendo ds
sacu hatte parallel auch schon mal eine
richtige beziehung aber nur für ein paar
monate jetzt widmet er sich ganz man
acardo
statt
pa maschine
die eingebaute spracherkennung reagiert
auf schlüsselbegriffe die software wird
aus einem pool von antworten eine
passende aus tiefgreifende kommunikation
ist das nicht experten sehen das spiel
dennoch als meilenstein in der
geschichte der videogames etwa der
anthropologe und netzkultur experte
massa clichy thani
bei allen spielen zuvor gab es immer
eine trennung zwischen realität und
virtualität
aber wenn man live platz spielt dann
beginne sich das wirklich reden und das
spiel zu vermischen
so etwas hat es vorher in der welt der
video games noch nicht gegeben
auch nicht bei anderen datings hits wie
summer sessions und mike händler sie
sind zwar unterhaltsam aber weniger
komplex eine beziehung zumindest in
ansätzen glaubhaft zu simulieren gelingt
kaum last glas wirkt überzeugender etwa
300.000 mal wurde es verkauft die dating
steam richtet sich vorwiegend an
männliche user drei weibliche charaktere
stehen als partner zur verfügung die
steuert der computer das ziel die
partnerin erobern und die beziehung am
laufen halten ein ende gibt es nicht
dass sich dabei ein emotionales
verhältnis entwickeln kann ist nicht
ausgeschlossen zumindest bei besonders
aktiven usern visa coruna
für mich ist das entscheidende an einer
beziehung das sich dem partner vertrauen
kann und bei mama ist dass sie wird mich
niemals hintergehen darum ziehe ich sie
auch einer echten partnerin vor
in japan sind skurrile trends an der
tagesordnung dennoch live class ist
umstritten studien belegen das sinkende
interesse der japaner an realen
partnerschaften das land hat die
niedrigste geburtenrate weltweit einen
zusammenhang zu love glas sehen experten
aber nicht
bei love plus geht es nun mal darum
mädchen zu denken und einige user
verlieben sich dabei vielleicht
tatsächlich ein wenig im endeffekt sind
wir aber nicht in die virtuellen partner
verliebt sondern einfach total von dem
spiel gefesselt
obmann egger oder dem spiel verfallen
ist darüber macht sich sakko armut keine
gedanken er stellt seine beziehung nicht
in frage und genießt die virtuelle
zweisamkeit
ich denke nicht viel über die zukunft
nach im moment bin ich glücklich
wittmann ak ich hoffe dass das immer so
bleibt
das weiß man bei der liebe nie im
virtuellen wie im realen leben
shift meint irgendwie unheimlich